my uh guest tonight of course a terrific
actress who starred in that 70s show and
is the voice of mega on family guy
she's also appeared in such movies as
black swan ted
and bad moms her latest film four good
days is streaming right now she's been
very nice to us
uh over the years please welcome our
friend mila kunis
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
it's so weird isn't that nice do you
feel weird in front of a crowd or i i
felt
immediate relief when we got our first
crowd there's like an aspect of it it's
like a little emotional you know what i
mean like you feel like the world was
ending yesterday and all of a sudden
you're like i'm at the largo and
everything's okay
yeah that's a nice feeling i think we
all feel that way
yeah this is really nice look at your
beautiful audience
so yeah we don't know how beautiful they
are because they're still wearing masks
their eyes are real their eyes are
gorgeous i think some of the best
foreheads i've ever seen
i'm trying to think of uh because we all
went through this 15-month period but i
know that i ran into oh jerry
remember i'm trying to remember it was
because we sort of lived near each other
uh up at the beach and i let me remind
you yeah please remind me
i need so many celebrities
it's it's peak of pandemic july 4th
weekend
um my husband decides to procure
fireworks legally
and um and we're like listen it's for
the kids
no one's here you know we'll just set
them off on the beach it's gonna be safe
he's from iowa he knows how to do this
so we are setting off that said
fireworks
and no one's on the beach i mean it is
nobody there and all of a sudden
fireworks are like and then we see this
but with like a hoodie just like
i'm not mr burns on the simpsons
started you literally walked in like
this
well first of all that's my usual
expression yeah yeah
okay he does that when he sees people
enjoying themselves
i'm like the grinch yeah but it's dark
yes
it was hard to like fully understand
what was happening but i was with a
friend of mine at the time and she
turned to me she was
oh no i was like oh my god someone's
coming towards us we're going to get in
trouble
this person's coming coming just kind of
stains they're next to the pew pew
fireworks
and uh and she goes oh my god it's coded
i'm ryan and i was like oh yeah that
makes sense
do you remember i ran towards you yeah
and i was gonna hug you
yeah and i was like hey oh hey
hey yeah like all of a sudden i was like
i don't
but you know what women were doing that
to me long before the pandemic
my whole life has been hacked yeah and
we're good
we're good uh no it was so emotional and
it was so funny because
you're not describing you're not
describing accurately these were not
these fireworks i don't know where
ashton went to a don't legally he must
know people in the military
because the reason i came over is i saw
major explosions down the beach and i'm
on patrol you know
ashton's walking around he's like
wearing shorts and he's when they're
about done he's kicks over a giant cam
with his boot
it's just being from iowa i'm not from
iowa so for me i was like
this is wrong and he was like i got this
yeah and like set up a whole
course of legally purchased fireworks
yeah
these were the safest fireworks i've
ever seen that's for sure
[Music]
i do not walk around like that kid with
a hoodie
okay well whatever you know i got to
hide this thing you know uh
you know i remembered um i was thinking
about it today i think
you came on our show you were so
young i think it was and i was asking
someone today and they looked it up and
they said they think you came on my show
on your 21st birthday
yeah is that right yeah and i don't know
one of the first shows i've ever done
yeah the kindest nicest person to me
ever to this
day of all the talk shows that i was
ever privileged to do
you're hands down my favorite well that
we have a picture we
it's really it's really hard to be mean
to you to be honest with you but
but really tell us about the ones that
were shitty too
but we have a we have a picture here of
you on the first time and it's like your
21st birthday
oh my god how crazy is that yeah and
it's oh you're sweet
but you know you know what's amazing
about you
uh and and we we've talked about this
before andy there are people
it's rare most people sort of put on a
persona when they come on a little bit
you're always
you you're you if i run into you on the
beach you're you wherever i see you
you're you you're you
right here and you've always been kind
of you're just naturally
funny and fun to talk to were you
nervous when you first started going on
talk shows because you never seemed it
no i couldn't believe that i was allowed
to right like i didn't look at it as a
job or a chore like i
genuinely look at this as like i just
have to make sure i don't curse that's
the only thing
that's the only difference you can curse
here if you want we're on basic cables
i'm trying really hard i think this is
the only thing that i know that i
shouldn't do um otherwise i look at this
as just like a genuine opportunity to
like get to know other people
and like i grew up watching late night
like this is what i grew up on so for me
to be a part of it the first time i was
like
this is the coolest thing ever why would
i be nervous like i might never do this
again like i never
thought right that like i would see you
like a couple years later you know what
i mean like it wasn't something
how long has it been now almost 20 years
but like it's not something that i
thought would continue
um i want to ask you about your family
everybody good though i want to make
sure that you
yes we have two kids yes and i've seen
you guys with them and you're
i mean i have i've seen you ashton just
throws them
uh but then you'll go babe i don't know
why my bag hurts and i was like i do
cause you're old and chucking babies
like he doesn't
i mean old dish you know what i'm saying
over 40. yeah
uh no i i've seen him on the beach a
couple of times with you guys and you're
just
like real parents and he'll be he'll
pick one of the kids and just throw it
in the air and maybe catch it
maybe 60 of the time he'll go for it the
end is soft
yeah so they're they're six and four is
that right what are they into at those
ages
so my son's into cars
obsessed yeah with cars and we have
hundreds
of cars little toy cars um rc cars
cars cars that flip all cars of all
kinds and then my
um my daughter's into space so like
anything to do with outer space the
solar system
um that sounds right that all sounds
about right yeah
i mean it's yeah i think it's very cute
there was a
at school they like ask you like what do
you want to be when you grow up and my
daughter was like i want to be
um an astronaut chef and i was like
that's
like she likes cooking you know the food
up there is notoriously bad
so it's not why it's gonna change all
that
and uh and my son's answer was a
dinosaur
and so i was like well such a species of
life
you have my daughter who's like chef in
space and my son's like not t-rex
no it's funny because i would think that
you would you and ashley will be very
good at keeping your kids
grounded because i know when i first met
you when you would come on the show
you would tell these stories first of
all you would achieve this
amazing success of being on that 70s
show and being a star and being 21 years
old
but you would get into fights with your
parents and i remember you once told me
oh yeah i had a big fight with my
parents and so they took they grounded
me so i have to take the bus
to the lot to film that 70s show
yeah and i thought that is a amazing
parenting like
that's absolutely fantastic and b you
were like well you know that's what you
have to do
you you could have probably rented your
own helicopter you didn't do it
i guess i i i did yes it happened twice
and they took my keys what did you do to
get grounded
you know what to this day we're tr i
probably talk back like
you know i've i come from a very old
school family so it doesn't it it was a
very good kid but you just don't talk
back like
um and uh they took my car keys away and
the first time
my parents left me a dollar 25 where my
car keys normally are and they both went
to work and i woke up
ready to go to my car and go to work and
then there was like a dollar 25 and i
was like
so you get on the bus you take it to the
lot you get off in front of the lot and
you go in
to be one of the stars of a tv show yes
and guess who drove me home
was it ashton yeah yeah sweet
it's very sweet we have a couple of
those stories yeah i also hated
chemistry
hate it very good at physics calculus
math loved it
hated chemistry and uh to this day he
likes to tell everyone
that he did all my chemistry homework
for me
[Laughter]
was that true did he 100 wow all right
now you guys have been during the
pandemic you were homeschooling your
kids kind of you have to
you have to we homeschooled until we
didn't
so i
that would be like two days yeah yeah
so they can't read
it's fine they're a speech reader um
uh well let me tell you conan i have
skills in life
and uh being a teacher is just not one
of them
and that's okay like that's okay the
second
we finished off that last year and then
in the new school year we started a pod
school
and hired wonderful tutors okay yeah
you tagged out at a certain point i did
because it was hard to work full-time
and teach the children and parent the
children like
it was it became none of us liked each
other i didn't like them they didn't
like me
it was just it wasn't right
i completely know my my kids are very
happy when i go someplace
they like to see me come home for a
brief period of time
they like evidence that i've come home
and then they don't want to see more of
me yeah so
if i was around all and especially if i
was trying to teach them anything it
would be insane
yeah yeah my kids like me a little bit
more than that but like
all right i want to ask you about this
you have jumped into the world of
cryptocurrency and you talk about it
i don't understand it and i know people
say i don't understand it
i honestly don't understand it i've
asked my son who's very bright at this
stuff to explain it to me
and he says i don't he doesn't want to
try because he knows i will not
understand
so i don't know what it's all about but
i know that you've really gotten into it
so yes in quarantine some people took up
baking and knitting and i deep dived
into crypto and nfts
and i'll tell you why like all jokes
aside is because it made me nervous
and i felt like it was a very masculine
um
area like everybody that i knew that
knew anything about it at the time was
always a man
and i was like it's gonna be that hard
and um
and you know it was the pandemic and so
i just deep dived into it and surrounded
myself with
two incredibly smart women that know
everything about it that you know
started libra for facebook and whatnot
and educated myself on on crypto on the
ethos of crypto and what crypto is in
the world of the you know
decentralized marketplace like
everything that it stands for
and um and found it to be really
empowering
and then i was like well this is fun
what next and then i decided to deep
dive into nfts
and so through the pandemic created a
piece of
a form of entertainment called stoner
cats that we're releasing
in a couple weeks that is an nft and you
can buy
such stoner cats and then that is your
token to then watch a five minute long
piece of entertainment it actually
sounds like it sounds like a cool idea
and i know you've had experience in
animation and comedy so
we have uh i think we have a picture
here of the stoner cats
this is yep and uh it's really cool guys
they're very guys yeah so here's the
thing
i was going to say cats just sit around
anyway
well guess what happens when they get
started um
the the so this was all done by really
brilliant people
in at home after work so the animator
the writer the director all the toy
story twos
and the spider-verse and space jam and
all these incredible
movies and uh the people that we got to
do the voices everybody just did it
because they thought that it was
different and fun and we all wanted to
do it for the right reasons and it
brings ownership
of content back to the artist and cuts
out the middleman and so if people like
the nfts and they buy it as tokens then
more shows will be made
we have a picture two of your character
peepee
yep yeah she's real cute guys check her
out
look at those eyes
[Laughter]
and you're really busy because you uh
you were working on four
good days and this is a very uh this is
a completely different tone obviously oh
yeah how do you get a transition from
this
there's no way to transit there's no way
to transition uh
that was it well this is pot and then we
get into a much heavier substance
uh the last topic was the gateway drug
for this topic
but it's it's really a harrowing story
this this movie is a really harrowing
story
yeah and it's about it's a true story
addiction true story yeah based on an
article that was written a couple years
ago about a mother daughter
and what i genuinely loved about it was
it's not a
story about drugs and it's not a story
about like why you shouldn't do drugs
it's not
it's just two people's um life set in
the world of four days and they just
have to survive these four days about a
young woman
this all happened an addict goes to
rehab public rehab
pays for three days of um of detoxing
and then
the next is up to you and there's a shot
you can get if you're sober for four
days
for seven days you can get a shot that
prevents you from getting high and so
she just has to stay sober for four days
and the the film is through the lens of
these two and blend clothes myself play
mother daughter and it takes place in a
house and it's just a matter
of worst year won't you that's amazing
your co-stars
i mean come on i just like glenn close
like it's no big deal it's a big deal
i'm totally aware i'm not gonna be an
[ __ ] i was like hey guys it's no big
deal right
it's a big deal yeah and being in
with her all day long every day was like
genuinely one of the greatest gifts that
i could have had and then pandemic hit
the day after we wrapped i mean it
couldn't have been any more like
the world is so amazing i'm working with
glenn close the world is ending
everything is shutting down and
everybody's
like it all was very extreme feelings we
have a we have a clip here
anything you need to tell us about this
i think it's pretty intense i think it's
pretty i mean it's
i i think you guys get it like the the
impetus of the film is she goes to rehab
she comes out of rehab she now has to
spend four days with her mom let's look
at this
uh clip from four good days
what drugs are you using heroin
methadone
some crap uh vicodin
and maybe adderall last time you used
yesterday morning so i'm hurting
how long have you been addicted 10 years
more have you ever been through detox
how many times um
14. excuse me 14 times
so
um this is fully based on real
like real events real life and uh and
glenn and i were both really fortunate
to talk to
both the women in in today and like it
isn't every day
it is day to day like there is no it is
a disease right and it's not one of
those right and everything's great and
there's a happy ending and everyone
it's not and this is the real life you
know eyes into it
yeah and i'm quite certain you could
probably talk to anybody
here and in this audience everybody
knows someone who's gone through this at
least somebody or a family member
it's insane how prevalent it is and
tragic but yeah
um good for you for doing this thank you
four good days yeah four good days
is available now uh on digital and video
on demand
and i'll say this you know we're gonna
pack this up and move on uh to other
things but
uh it is been a real treasure every
single time i talk to you whether it's
on this show or bumping
into you out in the world you're a real
person
and you're uh genuine and really funny
and lovely and uh just a joy to know you
so mila kunis thank you so much
seriously we'll take a break we'll be
right back